Let's keep doing some problems.
So in the last time I said,
what are the chances of not
getting any heads if I flip the
coin-- I was going to say dice,
but I realized we're
dealing with a coin.
If we flip the coin seven
times, if you said, well,
that's the same thing as
getting 7 tails in a
row, and that's 1/2
to the seventh power.
Because each trial there's a
1/2 chance of getting the exact
thing that we want, which
in this case is tails.
And you multiply it times
itself seven times
and you get 1/128.
It actually turns out that
there are actually 1/128
possible results that we can
get, equally probable results.
And why do I say that?
Well, what's the probability of
getting-- I don't know-- all
heads and then the last
flip I get is tails?
So heads, heads, heads,
heads-- so I'm doing it
seven times, rights?
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, and then
the last time I get a tails.
If you can think of it, this is
exactly 1 particular result out
of the total results
that we can get.
And what's the
probably of this?
Well, there's a 1/2 chance of
getting a heads, 1/2 chance of
a heads, 1/2 chance of heads--
let me switch colors-- 1/2
chance of a heads, 1/2 chance
of a heads, 1/2 chance of a
heads, and then 1/2
chance of a tails.
Once again, this is just 1/2
times 1/2 times 1/2 times
1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2,
which is equal to 1/128.
So any particular-- I don't
want to say combination because
we'll learn a little bit about
permutations and combinations
in future videos.
But any particular set of
circumstances we want is 1
out of 128 of the total
number of outcomes.
That what I should use.
Instead of circumstances,
outcomes.
If I have any particular
outcome-- so this is a
particular outcome, the way to
view it is there are 128
particular outcomes, so if I
choose one of them my odds of
getting it is 1 out of 128.
So let me ask you a question.
What's the probability of
getting exactly 1 heads?
So what does this mean?
This means I could get-- oh, I
could get tails, tails, tails
and-- let's say we're doing it
five times just so I don't
waste too much time.
Out of 5 rolls, out of 5 flips.
So that could be
tails, tails, heads.
That could be-- as you
can tell, I switched
colors arbitrarily.
That could be tails, tails,
tails, head, tails.
I think you get the pattern.
Tails, tails, heads,
tails, tails.
That could be tails, heads,
tails, tails, tails.
That could be tail-- oh sorry.
That could be heads,
tails, tails, tails.
So if we look at this way
there's this probability.
There's actually how many
events, how many outcomes,
would satisfy this
statement, exactly 1 heads?
Well, there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And the way you could think
of it is we're going to do
5 flips, exactly 1 of the
flips is going to be heads.
It could be any 1
of those 5 flips.
There are 5 situations
in which that happens.
And notice, I said
exactly one heads.
Because if I said at least 1
heads then we would have to
take into circumstances where
we have 2 heads and then it
becomes more complicated.
We'll learn more about that
when we do combinations.
So what are the chances of any
one of these possible outcomes?
Well, if we just
look at this one.
There's a chance of 1/2,
1/2, 1/2, 1/2, 1/2, so it's
1/2 to the fifth power.
Which is equal to 1/32.
And you use the same
logic each to these.
This is 1/32, 1/32,
1/32, 1 out of 32.
And in general, when I'm
flipping a fair coin five times
in a row there are going to
be 32 possible outcomes.
And each of these is just 1
of the particular outcome.
And we're essentially saying,
out of the 32 outcomes, 5
satisfy the event that we're
looking for-- exactly 1
heads out of 5 flips.
So there are 5 that satisfy it
out of a total of 32 outcomes.
And so using that definition
only if we can say that all
of the outcomes are
equally probable.
The probability is 5/32.
And then you could say, well,
let me make it a little
bit more complicated.
What is the probability of not
getting exactly one head?
So here there is a lot more
circumstances that satisfy it.
So for example, let me
throw out a couple
that would satisfy it.
Well, you could get all tails.
But also, if you got 2 heads
that would satisfy it because
you didn't get exactly 1 head,
So this would also satisfy it.
And so you might say, well,
if we do it like this
it's really complicated.
Or you could say, well, these
5/32 are the only outcomes that
don't satisfy-- that do not
satisfy this condition.
So the rest of the what?
32 minus 5 is what?
27.
The other 27 outcomes
will satisfy this.
So you could say that this
is equal to-- and this is
a common trick in a lot
of probability problems.
This is equal to 1 minus the
probability of getting exactly
one heads out of 5 flips.
And that is equal to-- 1 is
the same thing as 32/32.
Minus-- what's the
probability of this?
We figured it out.
It's 5/32.
And that equals 27/32.
So that's just always
something to keep in mind.
Sometimes when you get a
probability problem it seems
difficult to solve that
problem, but it's actually
not that difficult to solve
the opposite problem.
So you say, well, it's hard for
me to directly figure out the
probability of not getting
exactly one heads; I'd have to
know combinations
and all of this.
But this is the opposite of
getting exactly one heads,
and that's an easier thing
for me to figure out.
So if I can figure out that
probability, all of the other
outcomes would satisfy
the opposite one.
Hope I didn't confuse you.
So anyway, everything we've
done so far, it's been dealing
with coins and fair coins and
that's interesting to a certain
degree, but let's make it so
that the different outcomes
have different probabilities.
Let's do free throw percentages
because I think this is
something that we all-- if we
watch basketball or play
any basketball, we're
familiar with the idea.
So let's say that I, and this
is not true, I only could
wish-- let's say that I have
an 80% free throw percentage.
So that means every time I go
to take a free throw there's an
80% chance there's a basket and
that there's a 20% chance
there's no basket.
How does this come up with?
Well, we'll do more on
statistics later and they're
really-- probability and
statistics are opposite
sides of the same I guess
coin, you could say.
But someone says OK, out of the
last hundred times Sal took
free throws he's made 80.
So in general, he has an 80%
chance of making a particular
free throw, but it might
not have been a hundred.
I might have taken a thousand
free throws and I made 800.
But that's where you come
up with the 80% from.
So that's fair enough.
So the 80% is p, and then
a common notation is
the 20% is 1 minus p.
If I have an 80% chance of
making the shot, I have a 20%
chance of missing the shot.
So my question to you, let's
do kind of the same examples
we did with the coins.
What's the probability of me
making-- I don't know-- 3 shots
in a row, 3 baskets in a row,
or 3 free throws in a row?
I'm going to say free throws
because this is my free
throw percentage, not my
overall shot percentage.
Well, by the same logic
it's going to be equal.
The first one I would have to
get right, then the second one
I would have to get-- I would
have to get a basket and
there's a 20% I have no basket.
And then the third one I
would have an 80% chance
of getting a basket.
So this is-- I didn't draw
the rest of the tree.
It gets pretty broad.
But in general, just from the
coin example you can just
multiply these probabilities.
So 80% is the same thing
as 0.8, so you get 0.8
to the third power.
I don't know, what is that?
Let me see.
It is 0.8 times 0.8 times
0.8 is equal to 51.2
or 0.512-- 51.2%.
So I have slightly better than
even odds of making 3 free
throws in a row, which
is pretty good.
And as you can see, I don't
have an exponent on this
cheapo Windows provided
calculator I use.
I have to apologize for that.
So we might to limit
our exponent size.
But anyway, that should
hopefully-- well, that's
a little bit of a taste.
In the next video I'll do a lot
more examples with the free
throws and the basket, and
we'll even learn a little bit
about conditional probability.
See you soon.